von Claudia Pechstein steht bereit die
Olympiasiegerin im Eisschnelllauf
grundsätzlich für eine super Idee
wird hier die Entschuldigung für ein
neues Grundsatzprogramm Impulse aus der
Zivilgesellschaft erhofft
natürlich stehe ich hier in erster Linie
für den Sport und der Sport ist unser
Zivilgesellschaft natürlich spielt ja
eine große Rolle und ich darf mich jetzt
daran versuchen einen Impuls zu setzen
es wird sicher nicht es wird sie sicher
nicht überraschen wenn ich anrege
grundsätzlich den breiten vereins- und
Schulsport zu stärken nur wer hier gute
Bedingungen schafft darf darauf hoffen
dass der das auch der Spitzensport davon
profitieren kann
und dabei ist natürlich auch nicht das
Ehrenamt zu vergessen denn ohne Ehrenamt
finden keine Veranstaltung keine
sportlichen Veranstaltungen statt keine
Wettkämpfe auch ich habe davon jahrelang
profitiert und einen ganz ganz
herzlichen Dank auch auf dieser an
dieser Stelle an das Ehrenamt
wir haben hierzulande rund 86.000
Vereine mit mehr als 23 Millionen
Mitgliedern das entspricht etwa 37% der
deutschen Bevölkerung das ist gewaltig
und dennoch gehen die Zahlen und läufig
der Nachwuchs ist häufig lieber zu Hause
vor der Konsole als ich aktiv zu bewegen
das Problem beginnt schon in der Schule
in die Hände klatschen ein paar
Kniebeuge machen reicht für die Kinder
genauso wenig wie nur eine Stunde Sport
im wöchentlichen Unterricht schon jetzt
haben viele Kids Probleme ein kurze Baum
zu schlagen
das sollte uns alle alarmieren denn
grundsätzlich gilt mangelnde Fitness in
früheren Jahren wird nicht dazu
beitragen später die Gesundheitskassen
zu entlasten
vom mangeln Anreiz für den Spitzensport
ganz zu schweigen ich kann es aus meiner
eigenen jahrelang Erfahrung berichten
dass heute auf weltcupreisen die nächste
Shoppingtour für manche Läuferinnen den
gleichen Anreiz ausübt wie die
Wettkämpfe auf dem Eis und es gab Zeiten
das da war das undenkbar
[Applaus]
ich bin ich bin nicht hier um meine
eigenen Leistung zu schmälern aber es
dürfte eigentlich nicht möglich sein
dass eine 51-jährige in einer
olympischen Sportarten noch Deutsche
Meisterin wird bei unseren Nachbarn in
den Niederlanden wäre ich schon längst
in der Rente
um es mit dem Worten von Altkanzler
Helmut Kohl zu sagen Leistung muss ich
wieder lohnen es gibt Nationen da haben
Olympiasieger für ihre spätes Leben
ausgesorgt ich habe fünf Mal olympisches
Gold gewonnen und bin trotzdem weiter
von entfernt da ich da ich in meinem
Alter auch weiter von entfernt bin ein
sechstes Mal Olympiasiegerin zu werden
kann mir niemand Eigennutz unterstellen
wenn ich anrege das ist grundsätzlich
keine schlechte Sache wäre olympisches
Gold nicht nur mit 20.000 Euro zu
entlohnen
[Applaus]
der oder die beste der Welt im Sinne der
olympischen Gedanken zu sein ist mit
großen Entbehrungen Disziplinen Willen
und auch mit Qualen verbunden glauben
Sie mir ich weiß wovon ich rede
wenn wir sportlich wieder ganz vorne
mitwischen wollen dann gilt der kölsche
Grundsatz umso mehr damit sich Leistung
wieder lohnt sollten auch die
förderplätze der Bundeswehr und auch bei
der Bundespolizei und da wären wir schon
längst beim nächsten Impuls
grundsätzlich an harte
Leistungskriterien geknüpft und nicht
verschenkt werden
überhaupt scheint es mir so dass derzeit
viel verschenkt und zu wenig entlohnt
wird ich bin selbst jetzt seit
Jahrzehnten Bundespolizisten als
Polizeihauptmeisterin stehe ich mit
meinen Kollegen im regen Austausch und
es ist für uns alle unstrittig dass man
Menschen in Not helfen muss aber wenn
Menschen zu uns kommen und Asyl
beantragen und einen Richter nach
Prüfung aller Fakten zu dem Schluss
kommt dass der Antragsteller kein Recht
hat hier zu leben dann versteht niemand
dass solche Menschen einfach hier
bleiben dürfen
[Applaus]
wenn ich richtig informiert bin reden
wir derzeit etwa über 300.000 solcher
Fälle wir sollten grundsätzlich die
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen um dieses
Problem recht stattlich zu lösen so
erleichtern wir nur nicht nur die Arbeit
der Polizei Kolleginnen sondern auch
grundsätzlich für mehr sicher sorgen
auch grundsätzlich für mich mehr
Sicherheit im Alltag der Menschen allein
die öffentliche rechtlichen
Verkehrsmittel zu nutzen zu können ohne
ängstliche Blicke nach links und rechts
werfen zu müssen gehört zum Beispiel
gehört zu den Alltagsproblemen die viele
besonders ältere Menschen unter Frauen
belasten
darüber wird wie viel zu wenig
gesprochen meiner Meinung nach hierfür
Verbesserung zu sorgen sollte uns
grundsätzlich 100 mal wichtiger sein als
darüber nachzudenken ob wir einen
gender-sternchen setzen oder ob ein
Konzert noch deutscher Liederabend
heißen da
oder ob es noch erlaubt ist ein
Zigeunerschnitzel zu bestellen das sind
Themen die viele Menschen bewegen und in
den familienkopfschütteln diskutiert
werden ich bin selbst ein
ausgesprochener Familienmensch womit wir
auch schon beim nächsten Impuls sind
denn ich den ich als Abschluss setzen
möchte die CDU ist immerhin die Familien
ist tschuldigung die CDU ist immer die
Familienpartei Deutschlands gewesen und
ist es nach wie vor meine Eltern habe
ich haben mich und meine Geschwister mit
viel Liebe zu anständigen Menschen
erzogen eine intakte Familie ist auch
ein Idealbild von dreiviertel der
deutschen
in der Shell Studien über die
Zukunftswünsche unserer Kinder stehen
gute Freunde und Familie ganz weit oben
gerade wegen aller gerade wegen aller
Probleme um sie herum die Kinder hier zu
Lande wollen nicht nur einen guten Job
eine heile Familie eine
traditionelle Familie sie wollen Mama
und Papa
die Familienpolitik der christlichen
demokratischen Union sollte sich
grundsätzlich zuallererst mit der
traditionellen Familien beschäftigen
weil wir aufhören die familienparteien
im Lande zu sein dann werden wir auch
nicht mehr Volkspartei in Deutschland
sein
Claudia Pechstein die fünfmalige
Olympiasiegerin im Eisschnelllauf mit
einem Plädoyer dafür das traditionelle
Familienbild in den Kern der Betrachtung
zu stellen bei der CDU